je suis né le 28 avril 1882 à tortis
envers petit village bien joli du
calvados dont on aperçoit le clocher à
main gauche contre eux vers troarn
en quittant livarot mes parents tenaient
un commerce d'épicerie qui leur laissait
bon an mal an 5000 francs de bénéfices
notre famille était nombreuse d'un
premier lit ma mère avait eu deux
enfants est lutte avec mon père à fils
et quatre filles
mon père avait sa mère ma mère avait son
père ils étaient quittes si j'ose dire
et nous avions en outre un oncle sourds
muets
nous étions 12 à table du jour au
lendemain un plat de champignons me
laissa seul au monde seule car je vais
voler 8 sous dans le tiroir caisse pour
m'acheter des billes et mon père en
cours ou s'était écrié puisque tu as
volé tu seras privé de champignons ces
végétaux mortels c'était le sourd muet
qui les avait accueillis et ce soir là
il y avait onze cadavres à la maison qui
n'a pas vu onze cadavres la foi ne peut
pas se faire une idée du nombre de
cadavres que cela fait il y en avait
partout par le rêve de mon chagrin
disons plutôt la vérité je n'avais que
12 ans et l'on conviendra que c'était un
malheur excessif pour mon âge
oui j'étais véritablement dépassé par
cette catastrophe et n'ayant pas à cette
expérience pour en apprécier l'horreur
je m'en sentais pour ainsi dire indigne
on peut pleurer sa mère ou son père ou
son frère
mais comment voulez vous pleurez 11
personnes
on ne sait plus où donner de la peine
je n'ose pas parler de l'embarras du
choix c'est pourtant après cela qui se
passait ma douleur sollicité à droite
sollicité à gauche avait des sujets de
distraction trop nombreux le docteur
lavignac appelé dans le courant de
l'après midi ne cessa de prodiguer
pendant des heures et des heures ces
soins éclairé mais hélas inutile ma
famille c'était niet inexorablement
monsieur le curé qui déjeunait ce jour
là chez le marquis de beauvoir dit
arriver vers 4h à bicyclette on allait
avoir bien besoin de lui
dès cinq heures du soir tout le village
était chez nous le père rousseau
paralysée depuis 20 ans s'était fait
porter jusque là et l'aveuglent aurait
peut-être en poussant les autres
laissez-moi voir laissez-moi voir
j'avais été renvoyé de chambre en
chambre par les ouazine aussitôt accouru
et ne sachant plus où me fourrer je
m'étais craintivement dissimulé sous un
comptoir dans la boutique de la
j'entendais tout ce qui se disait tout
ce qui se murmurait les premiers décès
avait été annoncé non sans une certaine
confection ainsi qu il est de règle
mais dès la quatrième heure les annonces
de vienne brève et bientôt laconique
encore un et tous ces villageois résigné
et fourbus reprenait de la vie devant
toutes ces morts il leur semblait sans
doute que chacun est à voir un peu plus
d'air à respirer dorénavant et je
percevais des dialogues si nous y est la
grand-mère pas encore mais c'est la
sphère de 20 minutes
il en reste combien +4 l'oncle assassin
le sourd muet mourut le dernier dans
d'horribles souffrances
quel est celui qui crie comme ça c'est
le muet répondait-on lorsqu à cette
heure tout fut fini je suis sorti de ma
cachette et je me suis trouvé nez à nez
avec le docteur et raté qui s'est plongé
le front il me vie
le regarda le reconnut n'en crut pas ses
yeux et me dit et bien et toi et il y
avait dans sa voix une surprise immense
avec un rien de blâme d'ailleurs il
ajouta qu'est ce que tu fais là
et ce qu'est ce que tu fais là ne
voulait pas dire qu'est ce que tu fais
là sous le comptoir non non il
signifiait bien qu'est ce que tu fais là
sur la terre en effet de quel droit
n'était pas mort comme tout le monde
il continua tu n'as pas mal non pas du
tout mais comment se fait-il
et maintenant il ne me regardait comme
si j'étais un phénomène ou bien le
diable ce garçon de 12 ans qui absorbait
pas pu naiman des champignons vénéneux
qui survivaient à tous les siens
ça devenait très intéressant pour lui
quel champ d'expérience et comme il m'a
semblé qu'il se voyait déjà penché sur
mes viscères j'avoue et la vérité j'en
ai pas mangé
pourquoi est ce pourquoi parti très vite
était extraordinaire des formations
professionnelles je le veux bien mais je
jure qu'il l'a dit sur un ton de
reproche
et comme il répétait pourquoi pourquoi
je préférais tout dire j'ai raconté mon
crime et j'ai dit qu'elle avait été mon
châtiment alors dans une esquisse de
sourire il eu un clignement d'oeil qui
semblait dire toi
pas bête l'histoire fait rapidement le
tour du village et je laisse à penser
qu'elle comment attirer le souleva le
jour de l'enterrement
derrière ces onze cercueils que je
suivais la tête basse et les yeux secs
je me demandais si le fait d'abord été
miraculeusement épargnée ne me donnait
pas un peu l'air d'avoir assassiné tout
ce monde
cependant que dans mon dos on chuchotait
savez vous pourquoi le petit n'est pas
mort parce qu'il a volé oui j'étais
vivant parce que j'avais volé de là à en
conclure que les autres étaient morts
parce qu'ils étaient honnêtes et ce
soir-là m'endormant seul dans la maison
déserte
je me suis fait sur la justice et sur le
vol une opinion peut être un peu
paradoxal mais que 40 ans d'expérience
n'ont pas modifié
[Musique]